so the new bat woman uh
tv show came out
and
you got to think you know new bat woman
you're going to get a lot of people that
are going to tune in
to see this new show it's like dude
women of power it's it's so
it's so hot right now so check it out
you're gonna love this news article
ready so i mean that's what you're uh
that's what you're dealing with
uh with what happened with the new bat
woman
show um yes batwoman
season two drops 80. listen man
this is the doctor doctor who just give
you an example with the female doctor
which is again another [ __ ] terrible
experiment they did
dropped 60 percent in the ratings
80 drop
in the ratings and you're right go awoke
go broke
that's not just a saying that is a that
is an
observable scientific phenomenon
an observer observable scientific
phenomenon
80 [ __ ] percent
so they lost data they're eight of their
10 viewers yeah two people are watching
it now
and the two people that are watching it
the two
the two people that are watching it are
people that are watching it to make fun
of it
i haven't even watched it but anyway
critical drinker poked this out and i
want to go through it because
i haven't watched the episode and have
no plans on doing it so uh let's let's
see what he has to say and again i like
promoting this guy he does really good
work
jesus wept what the [ __ ] have i just
witnessed i mean it's no secret that
batwoman's only real source of interest
is to be an entertainment lol cow for
reviewers like myself
right from the start it was always a
ridiculous ham-fisted attempt to craft a
serious crime drama from some of the
most unlikable
paper-thin characters played by some of
the least talented actors on television
a show so relentlessly comically woke
that it was basically guaranteed to
repel anyone who didn't dye their hair
purple
and weigh less than a metric ton why i
love the guy come on
how do you not love this guy show seemed
to be on its deathbed after season one
with yeah catco industries um they
brought up caco in supergirl
which is basically i mean like the
female version of lexco
abysmal reviews viewing figures that had
fallen through the floor
and this is just the first season oh my
god look at that
1.8 million and by the last episode it
was 0.64
on a star that had seen the way the
winds were blowing and
are we supposed to pretend ruby rose is
attractive or we were lying no one
thinks he's attractive right
promptly abandoned ship but damn if the
cw didn't find a way to keep this
frankenstein's monster
lurching onward just a little further
and the other day
i had the dubious pleasure of finally
experiencing the first episode of season
two
see you guys guys so uh before you get
into the second the second episode which
we're about to hear
she's a so that's pretty cool
and since i covered the trailer well i
guess i have some kind of professional
obligation to give it a look
so let's get into this shall we the
episode kicks off by introducing us to
new girl ryan wilder who's fast asleep
in her camp
phantasons baby ravan down by the river
one night
when pieces of a jet plane start falling
out of the sky all around
her why the [ __ ] are you throwing up nah
maybe she read the script
that's a really good point thank you mr
drinker let me just let me just expand
on that a little bit here
buddy um i would love to get him on the
show i'm going to try to reach out to
him
so let's let me let me let me
put something out here because i think
it's worth worth talking about
the woman who's about to become bat
woman who's supposed to be this
badass [ __ ] crime fighter
is throwing up at the side of an
airplane crash
for this episode
so she's stumbling around through the
wreckage and what should she
find
hold on wait a second i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
so i remember correctly
ruby rose's bat woman whatever her name
was cat
liquor [ __ ] it was cat licker look it up
for me
was ruby rose's [ __ ] batwoman's name
kate cat licker
i'm pretty sure i don't know tell me
look it up correct me but if not we're
going to be calling her cat like her
through the rest of this
so cat licker the original batwoman got
got on a plane at the end of the first
one and then they did your [ __ ]
typical [ __ ] trope and then oh no the
plane fell
down over the water like what the [ __ ]
like seriously
that's what they're doing with this now
again i haven't seen this episode
so i'm only going by what he's saying so
kate kane okay well whatever i was close
i was close
cat licker k kane whatever cat licker um
and the plane crash was she wearing the
suit or was it like in a trunk
and wasn't this the end of the dark
knight trilogies the christopher nolan
ones
when the bat plane exploded but then it
turned out that [ __ ] batman was
bruce wayne was alive and alfred saw him
in france or whatever
okay i'm not sure to overthink this
please mr drinker take over
i guess ruby rose was on the plane when
it crashed but it does beg the question
where the [ __ ] did she go
did she like fall out of the bat suit
sometimes
anyway whatever she's officially listed
as missing in action now
because i guess the writers are still
convinced that ruby rose might come back
someday then do grey scotch shows up at
the crash site looking for kate and
honestly
i think a little piece of this man's
soul guy's a legitimate actor by the way
must have died with every passing
episode seriously if this show isn't
even good enough for ruby rose
what the [ __ ] are you doing here mates
paycheck my friend
paycheck but cometh the hour cometh the
man
and in gotham's hour of greatest need
bruce wayne miraculously returns from
i'm sorry but that's not that's not
bruce wayne
from the dead to take up the mantle of
batman once again
no way yeah right as if warner brothers
would trust these morons with such an
important character
what we actually get is some [ __ ]
wearing bruce wayne's face
so he can infiltrate wayne enterprises
and take over so wait i'm sorry are they
doing the hush storyline
from the batman comics because that's
actually a really cool storyline they
could have done that in a movie or
something
and they're just going to do the hush
storyline and give it to [ __ ] black
one back
batwoman over the company i love how
nobody questions how or why he returned
after vanishing for like
five years and they just immediately
give them full access to everything
even discount morgan freeman doesn't
think it's weird that he now acts like a
complete
okay this kept morgan freeman pretty
funny totally different person
and apparently oh hush is a major part
of season one
okay i never watched again i haven't
watched this show you know i have so
even so
but so wait a second so they're
absolutely they're they're ruining
the hush chara the storyline which is a
really good storyline
he doesn't know his way around his own
office but he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he wants to be the real bruce wayne now
but to do that
he needs to get his hands on the bat
suits wait a minute you can't just steal
the bat suit and pretend to be batman
oh wait i guess you can okay so bali i
guess bali you've seen the first season
so let me ask you
so let me ask you because you've seen it
and again i haven't seen that i haven't
even seen this critical twinkle thing i
i
i started well i got maybe two minutes
into it and then i stopped
to start the show um
so question are they implying that
she made her bat suit out of bruce
wayne's bat suit is is that
is that what happened i mean i think so
right she made her bat suit
out of bruce wayne's bat suit correct it
sucks have to wait for the lag now
before he could answer but bali's seen
it that's why i'm asking or if anybody
else has seen it that's fine too
i'm just i wonder i'm just wondering
yes okay so yes so wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
she didn't even make her own bat suit
made her bat suit out of
bruce wayne's old bat suit and where'd
bruce wayne go did they explain it
and brian's got a good point doesn't
batman always have like 30 bat suits in
the batcave like different ones
all right we'll continue mr drinker
please [ __ ] knows what he'd actually do
with it anyway
considering it's now been drastically
altered sorry i mean
made perfect in order to fit ruby
rosie's
uh
oh yeah what was it was it nick that you
was it nick that said that she was hot
her body was hot
is that her is that is that her hot body
huh
oh man look how hot she is yeah look at
that does she have
less extreme physique why do you even
need that suit anyway
like with all the resources and
technical expertise at wayne enterprises
can't you just manufacture another one
the bat suit itself was never
particularly special in the comics
and bruce usually had multiple backup
there you go exactly
perfect point just in case one got
damaged but nah no it's like the [ __ ]
excalibur of the show
i've seen her in orange is the new black
she's not hot
stop pretending yes then disco
morgan okay i'm sorry i missed that part
so wait so the bat suit is like passed
down like a legacy thing like it's
it's given for even in batman beyond he
didn't give the new batman his bat suit
he made a new bat suit for him
got damaged but nah no it's like the
[ __ ] excalibur of this show i guess
then discount morgan freeman gives him a
chunk of kryptonite which is
why what apparently the only thing that
can penetrate the bat suit
i thought kryptonite well i know
kryptonite
was was made cause they could pe it
could kill superman right like you could
shoot a kryptonite bullet it would hurt
superman
why would you need a kryptonite bullet
to hurt forget even all the sjw stuff
because i'm sure that's
bad but the writing outside of the sjw
stuff is horrible
why would you need a kryptonite bullet
to penetrate
i don't understand no batman's not from
krypton
bro
i'm gonna calm down i'm gonna calm down
let's just keep watching and i'm sorry
mr drinker go ahead
count morgan freeman gives him a chunk
of kryptonite which is apparently the
only thing that can penetrate the bat
suit
what the [ __ ] is this thing made from
superman
anyway keep that kryptonite in mind
because it'll be important later
so then it's back to ryan who's
apparently a criminal on probation
and she's angry with her probation
officer because it's hard to find a job
when you've got a criminal record
no [ __ ] lady that's why you're not
supposed to break the law in the first
place
also if an oppressed protagonist
abandoned by society
appealing for help to a disinterested
bureaucrat looks strangely familiar
that's probably because you saw it in
another dc movie a while back
what did i say what the [ __ ] did i
say a couple days ago when we did this
what did i say
this i'm glad other people are noticing
it that's exactly what they trying to do
with the scene
they're trying to do the whole [ __ ]
joker vibe
but society has failed her
[ __ ] oh my god
that's probably because you saw it in
another dc movie a while back
all i have are negative thoughts
i know they say that if you're gonna
steal then steal from the best but damn
the idea of batwoman actually putting
itself on the same playing field as the
joker just
warms my hearts god bless you cw
never change anyway i think you get the
point here
ryan is a down and out and she takes
basically every oppression box possible
but now that she has the bat suit
that can only mean one thing time to be
powerful
why
[Laughter]
[ __ ] sake man i honestly hoped that
that was just a line for the trailer
but nope there it is loud and proud for
all to see
i love how the writers of this show have
literally never heard of the concept of
irony
so now that she's suited up it's time
for die
spider-man reverse bat women to kick
some criminal arse
cue another clumsy fight scene with the
world's most accommodating stunt man
cue more cringe-inducing one-liner most
accommodating sidemen
good goddamn point she wouldn't be able
to beat these people up
and cue disgusting soundtrack that
absolutely doesn't match with what's
happening
perfect work as always cw we also find
out that diverse batwoman's mum got
murdered by alice's gang back when she
was younger
wow what are the odds that this random
stranger would have such a personal
connection to the show's antagonist
[Laughter]
so discount morgan freeman tracks her
down to get the suit back
but she's like nah it'll be fine then
she gives him a lecture about how
oppressed
she is and how she deserves the suit
because her life has been hard
[ __ ] hell the show has literally
given us a lecture about social justice
so what i would love to see that ah [ __ ]
am i gonna have to watch this
i don't want to watch it but am i going
to have to is it going to be a friday
thing
i was going to watch that's adequate
this friday but i'm going to have to
move it to
maybe next week because i was going to
do a joy of passing joy pessy is busy
this friday
should i watch the first episode of the
show
should i i don't want to
but i feel i have to
how is this show even real if he really
wants the suit back
why can't he just shut it down remotely
or tell it to self-destruct or something
oh yeah i think i can smell shite then
finally
someone figures out that fake bruce is
fake by tripping him up with something
that the real bruce should have known
it's a shame that discount morgan
freeman never thought about that before
giving him access to the bat cave
anyway fake bruce has had enough of this
[ __ ] so he randomly blows holes in the
bat cave
until he finds a tunnel leading to what
i guess is meant to be the batmobile
that's the batmobile in the show
a souped-up dodge charger
yep that's it that's the batmobile now
thank you
jesus i can't wait to see the [ __ ]
batwing also i have to question what the
point is in having a hidden tunnel
inside the bat cave which itself is
already hidden
that's like keeping a safe inside a safe
so fake bruce goes after diverse bat
women with the [ __ ] mobile and despite
having the most advanced attack vehicle
on the face of the earth he somehow
loses a [ __ ] minivan
but it doesn't matter because he tracks
her down anyway and blasts her in the
chest with a kryptonite shotgun round
damn there's no way you could survive
that she dead is she dead at least did
she die maybe she died
oh never mind how exactly did she
survive a direct hit from the only thing
powerful enough to penetrate the suits
why didn't fake bruce just shoot her in
the face why would bruce wayne have a
shotgun in the shipmobile anyway
don't know anyway then fake bruce breaks
diverse batman's favorite plant pot
so she gets really mad and punches his
[ __ ] face clean off
yes it is a corvette you're right queen
slay
then whoa whoa i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
so
sorry i need this point i gotta ask
something face clean off
yes hold on
wait wait a second please please wait a
second
bali you still here
and haven't watched the first season so
maybe you know
in the hush storyline which is one of
the last really good story lines that
they did in the batman comic books
in the hush storylines hush wasn't
wearing a bruce wayne mask
he had gotten he was he was a doctor he
got extensive plastic surgery
to look like bruce wayne are you telling
me
are you telling me
that what we were looking at was a guy
in a mask
so he had one of the best masks in the
world
i'm notice that i'm not even zoning in
on the [ __ ] sjw [ __ ]
queen slay then she walks straight into
wayne tower because i guess security
isn't a thing in this show
and she hands back the suit to discount
morgan freeman then everyone has a good
old cry
because you know the best part about
that i just noticed something
you know that you know it's not a great
show when they're already advertising
the next episode of the show
on the show
and then everyone has a good old cry
because it's been at least 10 minutes
since water leaked out of someone's face
alice cuddles up to a dead guy and it
looks like the kryptonite from the
shotgun round is leaking into diverse
batwoman's body
oh no i guess that means she's gonna
have to get involved in things again
and that's it that's the not so
triumphant return of batwoman
honestly trying to review this show is
like trying to critique a
three-year-old's finger painting
i guess you're supposed to be happy that
they managed to produce anything at
all everything that was bad about season
one is even worse here the ridiculous
contrived plot where supposedly
intelligent people
missed the most dead obvious clues
because the story needs them to be
stupid
the clumsy fight scenes that make mortal
kombat annihilation look like the raid
the goofy special effects cheap costumes
and flimsy uninspired sets
the batmobile that's literally just a
low-end sports car spray-painted black
the ham-fisted attempts to give diverse
bat women a meaningful reason for being
involved in this [ __ ]
not to mention some pretty sketchy
morality like how diverse batwoman
thinks she's entitled to steal the bat
suit
because she had a difficult upbringing
or wait no really is that hold on hold
on hold on
is that why she thinks she could just
take the bat suit
because her [ __ ] childhood was hard
who's seen this episode i guess bali
disappeared
but who who here has actually seen this
episode
this guy sounds drunk as [ __ ] yeah the
critical drinker he's [ __ ] rules
watch his videos he's amazing
so she had her fifis hurt when she was
younger so she could just take
one of the most iconic [ __ ] suits in
gotham
city she's entitled to steal the bat
suit
because she had a difficult upbringing
or how she irrationally hates kate for
being born into her rich family
until she finds out that she's gay which
apparently makes everything fine then
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
laughs
[Laughter]
turn into a rich family until she finds
out that she's gay
which apparently makes everything fine
then because i guess your sexuality
determines whether or not you're a good
person
that's a [ __ ] so she didn't like her
because she was a spoiled rich [ __ ]
but because she [ __ ] scissors with
people in 2021
that [ __ ] that's it that's fine then
it's okay then it's fine
the thing that's simultaneously tragic
and hilarious is just how serious the
show manages to take itself
despite its endless failures and
shortcomings the actors are genuinely
going for it here
doing their best to bring pathos and
drama into the most ludicrous of
situations
and they all have this kind of bleak
haunted look in their eyes
like they can't quite believe the show
is even still on the air well apart from
alice who i guess realized early on what
kind of [ __ ] she'd signed up for
and vowed to bring that across in her
performance if i had to say
something positive about this show i
guess javicia leslie is a marginal step
up from ruby rose in that she actually
has a personality
she's not afraid to have a bit of fun
with the role and give her character
some quirks and lighter moments
of course she still has to deliver
obnoxiously preachy lectures
but i guess that's par for the course in
shows like this if nothing else i have
to commend the cw
on their sheer self-delusion sorry i
mean determination
plodding relentlessly forward with a
flatlining show that has no justifiable
reason to stay on the air
ignoring the barrage of criticism and
outright mockery from every corner of
the internet
and even refusing to kill off its
previous main character
in the hopes that she might come back
someday
i mean you have to admire their optimism
i guess
thank you mr drinker and please
subscribe to critical drinker not that
he needs my help
he's doing wee better than i am or will
ever do
but does great reviews just [ __ ]
great reviews wow
it looks really really bad guys it looks
really
really really really really bad